Did you guys know that Facebook has their
own space program? Nowadays, it seems like
every mega billionaire has their eyes on space.
Zuckerberg has actually been in the space
scene for a decent amount of time now having
started Facebook’s space program in 2014.
But unfortunately, like Blue Origin, it doesn’t
seem like Zuckerberg has much to show after
several years of work. So, what happened to
Zuckerberg’s space program? Well, unlike
the traditional space companies that we are
used to, it doesn’t seem like Facebook has
any ambitions to actually build and launch
a rocket themselves. Facebook is more focused
on what can be accomplished using rockets
as opposed to the rockets themselves. This
focus has led to three primary projects which
are a drone based internet service, a satellite
based internet service, and a space probe
capable of traveling at 1/5th the speed of
light. Starting with the drone based internet
service, Facebook initially announced this
project in 2014 in conjunction with their
new connectivity lab. The connectivity lab
was created by hiring ex nasa and ascenta
employees, and the lab was tasked with working
on the internet.org project. This project
was a partnership between 7 major corporations
including Facebook, Samsung, Ericsson, MediaTek,
Nokia, Opera, and Qualcomm. The goal of the
project was to bring affordable internet access
to the 5 billion people around the world who
didn’t have it at the time. Each company
in the partnership had a specific role within
the project. The smartphone companies had
the task of implementing special antennas
into their smartphones that could access the
new internet service. The other tech companies
had the role of improving data compression
by making it cheaper and more efficient. And
Facebook had the role of designing and launching
the internet drones themselves. This internet.org
project was eerily similar to Google’s Project
Loon. The only difference between the two
projects is that Facebook proposed to use
drones while Google proposed to use a network
of balloons. Both of these solutions sound
super cool in theory, but they also seem super
impractical and pointless. Why were these
companies messing with drones and balloons
when they could just launch satellites to
provide internet service? Satellites can leverage
the gravitational force of the earth to basically
infinitely orbit around the earth with no
effort from the satellite. Drones on the other
hand have to constantly rotate their blades
to maintain altitude. While the latter option
is a much more inefficient solution, it shines
in two areas which are cost and accessibility.
Launching satellites is extremely expensive.
Even for SpaceX, each satellite ends up costing
hundreds of thousands of dollars. Not to mention
the cost of the rocket launch. Meanwhile,
flying drones will likely only cost thousands
of dollars each. If anything, it might cost
tens of thousands which is still only a fraction
of the cost of launching a satellite. Aside
from being much cheaper, the internet service
offered by the drone network will be accessible
by significantly more devices. Nowadays, smartphones
are the easiest and cheapest way to access
the internet. Because of this, entry level
internet users especially in third world countries
are much more likely to have a smartphone
than a computer. So, providing mobile internet
service is more effective than broadband service
when trying to reach individuals with no internet
access. And, here’s the thing, even the
top flagship phones do not have the ability
to communicate with satellites in space. So,
it would be foolish to think that people in
3rd world countries have smartphones that
can access satellite internet. Considering
all of this, the reason facebook was launching
drones instead of satellites is because drone
based internet would provide internet that
is much cheaper and much more accessible to
the lowest tier of internet users. Unfortunately
though, this ambition wouldn't quite pan out.
In the summer of 2016, Facebook would conduct
the first flight test of their solar powered
drone. This test was actually a massive success
and was quite promising. The test flight was
only supposed to last 30 minutes, but it would
end up flying for 90 minutes. Now, the goal
was to have the drone eventually fly 90 days
at a time, but this was a great start. The
same cannot be said about the landing though.
A strong gust of wind combined with software
issues would lead to one of the wings scraping
on the ground and a 20 foot section breaking
off. Facebook would end up correcting this
mistake in their second test flight, which
nailed the landing. But for some reason, Facebook
would decide to scrap the drone altogether
and shut down their manufacturing plant in
2018. This doesn't mean that Facebook gave
up on drone based internet though. They simply
ditched trying to make their own drone. Instead,
they would partner with Airbus in November
of 2017. Since then, we have heard about a
couple of test flights here and there, but
aside from that, there really hasn’t been
many progress updates. It’s assumed that
the companies are perfecting the drone and
if things go well, we could see a beta roll
out within the next couple of years. Moving
on, we have Facebook’s plans with satellite
internet. This sector really needs no explanation.
With satellite internet, Facebook is looking
to provide broadband internet service to second
tier internet users. These people usually
already have broadband internet or at least
mobile internet. But, their connection isn’t
the best, so Facebook along with SpaceX, Blue
Origin, and OneWeb are looking to provide
cheaper, faster, and more reliable internet
access to these people. Since Facebook doesn’t
have launch capability though, they have to
rely on rocket companies to launch their satellites.
Ironically, one of their first satellite launches
was in conjunction with SpaceX, and this launch
happened to be one of SpaceX’s only failures.
Since then though, Facebook has successfully
built up a constellation of 53 small satellites,
and they hope to launch a broadband service
in the imminent future. I’m not too sure
how successful such a service will be though.
Facebook will likely have a tough time matching
the prices offered by Starlink since they
don’t launch their own satellites. Facebook
also doesn’t have a massive subscriber base
that they can leverage. For instance, it looks
like Jeff Bezos and Amazon will be late to
the satellite game, but when they do enter,
it looks like they're positioned to become
the second largest satellite internet provider.
Not only would Jeff Bezos have launch capability
with Blue Origin, but he can also leverage
his massive prime subscriber base. I feel
like people would either just go with SpaceX
to support their mission or just go with Amazon
because it’s convenient. So, I’m not quite
sure why someone would choose Facebook or
oneweb over the competition. But that’s
just what I think, let me know if you guys
disagree. Anyway, that brings us into Facebook’s
final and likely their most exciting project
called Breakthrough Starshot. Zuckerberg founded
this project in April of 2016 with Stephen
Hawking and russian billionaire yuri milner.
The goal of the project is to send probes
to planets with liquid water. Planets with
liquid water are often called Goldilocks Zone
Planets because the fact that the water is
liquid proves that the planet is not too cold
or too hot. According to Zuckerberg, planets
that don’t have liquid water aren’t that
useful for human inhabitation. He previously
wrote quote “Mars has no water, so it would
be difficult to ever live there." Elon Musk
and his fans would likely disagree with this
notion, but it is true that terraforming Mars
into an Earth like planet would take thousands
and thousands of years. Zuckerberg claims
that "It's quite possible the closest planet
that humans could actually live on is orbiting
Alpha Centauri, and the only way to know that
for sure is to visit close enough to photograph
the planet, which is what this project will
do." The only problem with this idea is that
alpha centauri is 4.3 light years away or
about 25 trillion miles away. Even if we use
the fastest spacecrafts we have today, it
would take 30,000 years to get there according
to Zuckerberg. But, one of the main reasons
for such a long travel time is the large mass
of the spacecraft. Newton’s basic second
law states that force equals mass times acceleration.
So, if you decrease the mass substantially,
you can significantly increase the acceleration
and get much closer to the speed of light.
And this is precisely what Zuckerberg plans
to do. Advancing technology has made it possible
to manufacture extremely small cameras and
sensors. And Zuckerberg wants to build nanoprobes
called nanocraft. As the name suggests, a
nanoprobe is an optical device that measures
as little as just 100 nm in length. To put
that in perspective, you could fit 100 million
nanoprobes within a single square millimeter.
Now, it’s unlikely that Zuckerberg’s nanocraft
will be that small, but that gives you a reference
as to how small nanoprobes can get. Given
the extremely small mass of such devices,
Zuckerberg is hoping to launch these probes
using a laser beam that will launch these
probes at ⅕ of the speed of light. That’s
the same as about 134 million miles per hour
or 60 million meters per second. Even at that
speed though, it’s going to take quite a
bit of time to actually reach Alpha Centauri.
Zuckerberg expects that his nanocraft can
reach Alpha Centauri within 20 years after
launch. And once there, the nanocraft should
be able to identify any signs of liquid water
and extraterrestrial life on the planet. At
the end of the day, it’s no question that
space is the next big venue of growth, so
it’s not surprising that billionaires are
crowding into the space. So far, Zuckerberg
has been working with Airbus to deploy cheap
mobile internet world wide and rocket companies
to deploy cheap broadband internet worldwide.
Aside from this, Zuckerberg is determined
to find the closest signs of liquid water
and alien life with his nanocraft. Despite
the setbacks in all of these projects, Zuckerberg
has continued to persist forward. But only
time will tell which one of these endeavors
if any will evolve into something much bigger.
Do you guys think Zuckerberg has a real chance?
Comment that down below. Also, drop a like
if you guys love seeing the growing interest
in the space industry. And of course, consider
joining our discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.